anh
alo alo alo
anh alo cho các bạn các bạn nghe thấy
mình nói rồi ngoại
Em không biết nhận mic2 chưa cơ tự nhiên
tai nghe mày chẳng nghe gì cả
anh alo
anh alo alo đây Ok Ok rồi à
Ừ ok thì à
khi sex
thì mình đầu tiên thì mình sẽ tạo cài á
anh Linh Google Google Maps thai bị rôm
bởi vì mình thấy zoom hình ơn chị miễn
phí Hình như chị 40 phút thành ra là
mình chuyển qua Google mít nhé Chị sẽ
tạo một cái Google Mỹ thì cho các bạn và
thì
tại sao mình vẫn còn tại sao mình vẫn
còn dùng YouTube để mà
để mà làm vụ A để dụ chủ yếu là để mình
quay lại quay lại video để cho những
người nào mà không
không vào xem được nữa để xem
Ừ mình đang run đó Không biết các bạn ở
ru lòng mình đang rất là vui không biết
là có bữa hôm nay có như mình mong muốn
hay không
ờ ờ trứng nhỏ
ô
[âm nhạc]
kính nhỏ
ở đây mình hôm nay mình mua giá cho ông
biết rồi thì vọng cải thiện hơn tí
mắc làm gì sát và một mình đây cách mình
tầm 10 phút nữa
đừng Google mít này à
ừ ừ
à à
Ông Bà mình sẽ có
ừ ừ
Anh ở Đảng Đợi tí mình cho
cho tất cả mọi người
à à
ừ ừ
à à à à
em
không có cái vụ là phiếu
tắt đi việc là cứ phải hỏi Mỗi lần có
người nào đó xin vào
Nghe ca nhạc
ừ ừ
3000 có một tắt này đi được cái đấy à
à à
anh Đợi mình tí mình xem tìm cách tắt
vì nó có cái tóc này hồi nhưng mà tóc
này tắt hết toàn bộ tính năng của hót
không ổn
ừ ừ
Ừ ok
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà
anh có thể bỏ qua đoạn đấy Ra đây thì có
thể chỉ
cơ thủ công được nhưng mà còn cái đoạn
này nữa
cho mình mình sẽ cho các bạn điền cái
form vụ format for của mình để mà thoát
đâm ra đâm dựa trên tên là các bạn Bạn
nào muốn Giả sử bạn vào đây nhưng mà bạn
chỉ muốn nghe thôi
bạn không muốn hỏi vấn đáp này cái lờ
việc là mình sẽ
nhà mình cần gần gần như là mình sẽ
random theo từng bạn để mà ra được câu
hỏi các thứ kem giả câu trả lời nữa
ở đây mình mình sẽ ghi ở đây nhá
à à
thì các bạn sẽ điền vào điền vào cái
đường link này
ừ ừ
và
các bạn vào đường link nào mình mình
mình mình đang ở đây này các bạn nghe
thấy không ạ
và
các bạn vào đường link này sau đó đi
mình đã có ghi hướng dẫn ở đấy là gồm 3
câu hỏi
Ê bà câu hỏi hai câu thì sẽ lấy ngẫu
nhiên và
một câu thực hành công thực hành thì các
bạn sẽ
vào lại cái đường link đấy để mà
tôi tôi chắc phải cho ông nào làm tốt
cùng để mà
À cái nhỏ không có việc cho ông là làm
hút cùng nhỉ
gì Nêu cấu Duyệt Duyệt rồi Khó chịu quá
à
Ê thằng này thì sao nó được lên đến á
hơn 1 tiếng nó được một tiếng
Vì sao
Chrome
extension
Google beat đ
ở trước cửa cơ khác rồi
Anh chỉ cần biết xem ông lão trốn
khi sex
bố mẹ để lưu lại danh sách những người
vào thôi
xe ô tô cho này à
ừ ừ
Ừ cái hạn tiện ích chỉ để làm vụ này
các axit thử xem nhé
ờ ờ auto toy
chứ không phải này ông Tú cho rồi còn
auto kiểu
xe ô tô gì nhé
à à
ừ ừ
a How to a mood oreimo
à à
Ừ cái này ô tô do rồi
xe ô tô Ăn mít à
ở tx như không có rồi
em chẳng lẽ tôi làm đoạn gia Suite kiểu
cứ mỗi lần thấy nó hiển thị lên thì
cho tôi tôi sẽ cân nhắc phụ đề
à à
anh ở đây đấy
chị đánh giá 3 sao thương nữa
em bảo tui cày tôi cài luôn nhé xem còn
lúc nào cho ai nữa
từ lúc tạo phòng bật hả
Ừ ừ Tra lúc tạo phòng mình quên
thứ hai mình tặng lại phát nhỉ
À mà thôi bây giờ cài cái kia rồi mà vẫn
cả là gì
anh Linh câu hỏi tính câu hỏi trên này
mười mấy ông cha là mấy ông thôi mà tôi
cho không cho mấy ông che cho mày đã
tránh bị trôi câu hỏi mấy ông tre ở bên
YouTube nhé á
à à
nhà mình có chạy ra đâu
ở thời tiết X cái này ích này nó bị
em sai rồi theo kiểu là thực ra là đôi
khi phải cài tiện ích trước mà mới mở
cái này
cho
tôi thử tải lại trang xem có bị chết
không
bí mật a
cho lại chính cái của mình ạ
Cho tôi hỏi cho lại chính cái của tôi ạ
Vẫn chưa ạ
ừ à Nó ngồi vào sau không thấy đúng
không như thế Tôi ghim ở trên à
Ừ cái nó khó chịu ở điểm mà
cái thằng YouTube nó chỉ cho ghi một cái
cho Java với giá Switch khác nhau nhá
ông điên nói chết chứ sợ
à à
ừ ừ
à à ừ ừ
Ừ
đúng rồi tiện ích này có vẻ là nó tự
động hộ mình vụ vụ kia rồi Lạc quan như
thế
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ nhưng mà nãy giờ mình đang hơi start
start hơi sớm đấy
mỹ nhân Thái Lan là bây giờ nó đang có
phải bạn
Có phải bạn
vào mất rồi mà Cái này thì trong vòng 1
tiếng nữa là hết
Ờ Ờ
nói chung và các bạn điền cái link
Google form mà mình vừa mình vừa ghi mẹ
Ừ để để tạo để các bạn là tiền xong rồi
đấy mình sẽ random mỗi bạn thì sẽ có 2
câu hỏi chị hỏi trắc nghiệm đúng
anh xem mà không phải trắng nghiện mà
hỏi và đáp
ở
phần thực hành thì các bạn sẽ điền vào
trong cái
các bạn sẽ vào đây mình mình thì da mình
mới nghĩ đến mình hôm nay được rộng hơi
gấp này mình mới nghĩ để được mỗi hai
cái này một cái là cái để mà chạy Online
này các bạn đăng nhập vào vừa rồi mình
đăng nhập có vẻ có vấn đề thì nó không
gửi Mail về xác thực hơi khó chịu các
bạn đăng nhập vào các bạn cốt các thứ
sau đó thì có cái Tạo Linh để mà chia sẻ
gửi cho người khác đấy Cái thứ hai thì
các bạn hãy lên đây code của mình chạy
trên chính máy cá nhân Như hạn có cốt
lên đây để mà để mà lưu cái xe này có
điểm là khi mà lưu lại thì nó sẽ tạo một
cái đường link Sau đó các bạn gửi vào
trong cái link Google form để bạn sẽ bạn
gửi gửi vào trong Lingo former rồi mà
các bạn đã điên để mà I Dare mình sẽ
chấm mình sẽ chấm điểm nói cho mình sẽ
chấm điểm dựa trên 2 tiêu chí cả câu hỏi
thì vẫn đáp giữa cả
câu thực hành có thực hành thực ra thì
chắc à Để để cứ cho 10 giờ mình bắt đầu
chậm đi đấy ông ạ
Không không Thì có ông lại bảo là anh
chấm em chưa kịp làm xong rồi gì gì đó
cứ 10 giờ rồi tôi mới bắt đầu chấm Đức
Khánh và tôi có bố đưa cho mấy ông sau
thôi sẽ công bố bí ẩn có thể là qua
email của mấy ông ấy thôi nhớ đây có thu
thập cái email phải đúng rồi tôi thu
thập lại email mới ôm nhưng mà
anh nói Trung Hà gọi inbox inbox vùng
kín sao cái kiểu gì thế ạ
ừ ừ
chị nhớ Mạnh Tôi đang bị hơi chậm đúng
không Nếu không thấy mạnh tôi có ổn định
không ạ
ở
đây Nói chung là bây giờ đang có bốn Bạn
muốn bạn rồi ông ạ Mình sẽ
cho mình mình sẽ làm ngẫu nhiên luôn có
hỏi
chạy ăn đun có hỏi
à à
ừ ừ
Hôm nay tôi để random.org cho công bằng
Nhưng mấy ông nhé
à à
ừ ừ
anh alo đầu tiên ở bạn đầu tiên nha bạn
đầu tiên thì mình sẽ ngẫu nhiên số từ 1
cho đề nữa à
chỉ số này từ một máy bao nhiêu nhé mình
xem lại xem
ừ ừ
à à
cài đặt Đợi mình tí
mình đang hơi ngáo ngáo một tí hi vọng
các bạn không nào như mình
ở
đại từ 1 đến 41 đông lạnh từ 1 đến 41 ok
ạ sau đó tôi cứ loại loại loại trừ dần
các câu hỏi
hai câu đầu tiên của bạn Trần Công Trí
là cậu 28
câu 28 là câu
ở đây
What is BL ngoại
khi bạn chuẩn bị đi à
à à
em kết bạn xóa này nữa à
ừ ừ
Ừ
hỏi tôi nghĩ chỉ có cách đơn giản hơn
với làm như này là đun hẳn trong cái
danh sách như thế này
xem bữa Ông đã nào
ê kê Grand ôm hạn danh sách hiện nay
tôi ấn nó đum rồi hai câu đầu tiên Ừ nó
hợp lý hơn tôi đỡ mất công Xóa bên này à
Ở
đây câu câu của bạn kia sẽ là What is
pdl và kết hợp với câu này nữa How many
type of liquor đây Thực ra là hai con
ngoài khá Dễ không ạ ạ
ờ ờ
ờ các bạn đây
Bạn vừa rồi là bạn à
ý chí Mạnh Trí rồi bạn chứ không ở trong
cái Linh
Lingo Miss này để vào xem
các bạn các bạn truy cập vào cái pho đấy
sau đó đi vào cái link Google mít của
mình ạ để mà
ở đây để mà vào để mà on cùng mình để mà
trả lời nào
các bạn chí ạ
ở đây Tôi đang thấy thật 80 mấy ông đang
ngồi xem nhưng mà có về hả người truy
cập vào Google mít có phải là người ít
em ngồi người mà sẵn sàng trả lời Ở đây
còn ít hơn
ừ ừ
thế hả
Ở đây Ok
bạn bạn
ừ ừ
à à
các bạn có thể mở mic được đấy
Mở mới đi mà đi hello Mẹ ơi
không có con mình đang đeo tai nghe máy
à
Chúc các bạn nghe được bạn ấy nói gì
không ạ
ừ ừ
anh
alo alo Không không biết được trên
YouTube của nghe được các bạn ấy nói gì
không ạ
anh
nghe được em ạ
Ừ
nếu mà trên YouTube bạn nghe được trên
YouTube cho chứ không phải là trên
Google mít đâu nếu mà trên Google mít
các bạn truy cập vào rồi thì thì không
nói
Ừ Ok ok Thế bắt đầu thôi
em trả lời
à à
Xin chào 28
What is today tiếng Anh tiếng Việt
thường các bạn nên dịch kể câu đấy mày
mình hiểu thì em vẫn các bạn hiểu được
cái câu hỏi không sau đó thì các bạn trả
lời tiếng Việt thôi Ở tiếng Anh thì có
khi mình không hiểu thôi đi đi nghĩa là
data defaunation Anh Việt và ngôn ngữ
định nghĩa dữ liệu
ừ ừ
chỉ cần cao mồm
Khi
so sánh sự
khác nhau và giống nhau giữa unit và PES
ik-002
How many type of Chic girl không phải có
một đâu
[âm nhạc]
thì cơ
như là có ba kịch à Bống đó chính là chị
cơ enter trên insta enter giống với câu
pho có ngày nên chạy sau câu lệnh còn
instead of instagrok là thay thế câu này
con góc nghiêng dưới cơ kýđăng nhập
Ô
cái con
có bảo 4 kiểu mà
After Earth for giống nhau không
ở ngã telfor giống nhau Nó hiện lên đấy
thấy có thể gọi là 3 triệu được không ạ
ạ Ok thì câu con thực hành của bạn nhé
bạn tra Bạn ghi lại luôn này có giờ hàng
của bạn thì sẽ ra
sẽ sẽ ghi đầy đủ ví dụ của tất cả các
cái zê zê zê zê Alo các bạn của bạn biết
kết hợp với việc tạo một cái cơ bất kỳ
một trong ba cái kiểu chứ Câu vừa rồi mà
bạn vừa nói đúng không
Đây Ok Thế xong bạn đầu trông có vẻ
nhanh
kể tiếp theo bạn ạ
các bạn hay ơ ơ
các bạn K2 có đây không ạ
Ba mẹ đâu rồi bây giờ điểm điểm sông pho
mà nhấn nút tích form Ở Đây Rồi anh để
abc@gmail.com đậu xanh à
Nghe
có vẻ
mấy cái bạn Điền fairplay không không có
đây như vậy à các bạn Nguyễn Văn Vương
Nguyễn Văn Vương đẹp
có lên không ạ ạ
anh Alo ạ
à À cũng Nguyễn à Ok
đây lại Loan đun cho bạn có hỏi tiếp nhé
cài đặt lại tí mình Xóa bớt cái câu vừa
rồi trả lời vừa Tôi đã
đến đâu này
mình chưa cơ ok
à à
Ở đây có hai câu cho bạn
A là
Ừ khi nào đây Bạn giữ bạn như thế không
ạ
bây giờ thấy à thử dịch xem nào When
should repair a a
à
à Ai
Ừ khi nào chúng ta cần tạo sticker
cái ngày
đề
thi Chúng ta cần
Như là em cũng không nhớ rõ nữa như là
chỗ tạo
rõ
ràng buộc chữa các bảng với nhau gì vậy
khi con sau khi tạo chích thì nó sẽ được
à
khi Active Plane thì khi mà
như mình Insert vào nó nếu mà nó đúng
đúng nó thả mạn cái rèn buộc thì nó
không vô chích cơ Ai có chứ
ở đó
anh cứ in six-inch
Nói chung là insta live update
còn là
dml là
data mutilation language là ngôn ngữ
thao tác dữ liệu
Ừ ai cũng có Insert Delete với update
Trấn Thành khu
resort update Delete đun nóng rồi
cái vụ chích Grow vừa rồi bạn nhận hình
như là đang bị nhầm với cái việc là nó
là con trên đó là kiểu dàng mua hơn còn
cái chi cờ khi nào mà nên tạo chế cười
thì đó là khi mà mình cầm nào
chỉ cần là gần ngựa bắt các sự kiện khi
mà thay đổi gì gì đó đúng không ạ cập
nhật thay thay đổi gì đó thì mình cần
cầm chạy hơn một cái đoạn Lệnh gì cho
nữa thì đấy Lúc mà khi mình cầm đạo chữ
cơ Và và đương nhiên là thức câu hỏi này
là mình mình dùng Google dịch chỉ vài
cái này ra là cái tự Active kia là ra nó
không chuẩn chứ câu nó sẽ file nghĩa nó
được khi nào được kích hoạt thì khi khởi
động kiểu như thế thì được bắn đấy thì
thì cái chi cơ khi trụ bắn thì anh em
mình dựa theo
để tiện theo mình đã quyết lúc đầu có
thể là dml hoặc cả thậm chí ở DL đúng
không ạ
Ok bạn cũng hiểu na ná nhờ câu 1 có vẻ
là hơi bị nhầm đấy ạ
It is câu chuyện hót à
Ê
cho hỏi cái đường mật mà cứ nói đi bây
giờ sân khấu của mình
như là
mình để cho nón và là mình chán cái tác
động dữ liệu sai nữa nhỉ
3000 thế nó thường hay bị thiên hướng về
cái việc tạo check các thứ con trên đó
thứ kiểm tra về giao mùa cũng như kiểm
tra dữ liệu nhập vào chuyện này không
Đỡ đương nhiên là chiếc Hôm trước mình
có dạy là ý rất là vì mình cũng có kiểm
tra thêm một lần nữa việc là dữ liệu
nhập vào có thỏa mãn thì mới cho phép
nhập ý thì cái đấy cũng là một phần
nhưng mà nhưng mà cái chế cơ bản chất nó
là
trò chạy chạy khi mà có sự kiện xảy ra
và thường hay liên quan việc là
bạn muốn chạy hơn những câu lệnh gì đó
để can thiệp kiểu kiểu thế khi mà có một
sự kiện đó xảy ra thì nói chuyện hơn
ví
dụ và Miu hôm trước là mình sẽ chạy thêm
câu lệnh để mà Cập nhật lại số liệu
chẳng ạ Đấy nghĩa khi thử sự kiện đó xảy
ra thì mình sẽ chạy một đoạn code nào đó
nữa
à à
I do ca cảm ơn ạ
ờ ờ
cái câu câu thực hành của bạn thì sẽ là
cũng cũng tạo cho mình một cái chữ cơ
bất kỳ nhé và cũng tạo và
cũng ghi đầy đủ các câu dml mà bạn biết
ví dụ thôi ông ạ
thế này do ngòi Bạn cứ nộp qua cái link
rom kia để mình chậm nhé á
anh không nhận thấy lượt xem có về đám
đông phết đấy mấy ông vào đây Có vẻ hơi
ít nhỉ Sao mày không ngại quá Cái đấy xe
như nào ý Chưa Biết
à à
các bạn ấn vào một là vào cái Fe online
là các bạn Shine các bạn đăng nhập vào
được thì thì các bạn có cái nút chia sẻ
Mình nghĩ thế Tại nãy giờ mình đăng nhập
có vẻ không được nó không gửi mail về
cho mình em mình không không vào được
thì nếu mà không được thì các bạn chạy
cốt ở trên lô cồ bình thường thôi chạy
được thì các bạn lên cái ơn notepad.com
này này cho các bạn Có code vào trong
này thôi các bạn xếp là được Nó sẽ có ai
ra sự bạn xếp cái gì đó như thế này nó
sẽ có một linh là linh public như thế
này các bạn hãy gửi cái này cho bất kỳ
ai được thì chỉ cần điền cái link nè
trong cái Linh Google Ford vừa rồi để mà
mình chấm 10 giờ mình sẽ chấm bài các
bạn nhé
à à
Ừ
ok tiếp theo là bạn miễn thích Khanh có
đều không ạ
ở tại mẹ
alo anh nghe đấy Ok Ok Đợi mình tí lại
ngẫu nhiên Câu hỏi tiếp
hôm nay thử ta mình nên có sao đâu đấy
Dễ Xóa đi hơn
gì người của tôi chết rồi à
ở hai câu của bạn đây
à à
các bạn bạn thường dịch hai câu xem
thì
tại sao thủ tục lại
anh ạ
300 hợp lodia không nên giờ chưa làm gì
cả để nguyên tên parsley
ở
tại sao CPU
mang đến bảo mật cho SQL Server
em ạ câu còn lại là có bao nhiêu cách để
chèn một bản ghi vào một bảng ở
đâu Tại sao locedu lại mang đến bảo mật
cho SQL Server thì
anh nghĩ là
khi mua CPU nó à
ừ ừ
hình ảnh
Exciter trả lời câu thơ hay trước
bao nhiêu cách chèn một bản ghi vào bảng
thì
anh
em nghĩ là có
sử dụng
anh em kể tên luôn giữ em đến là nó sử
dụng mình ạ
ờ ờ
bộ phim sex into và hiệu Hanshin
ở nhà
1000 lý của mình cái câu này thì ra nó
cũng không khó phải như thế với các
phương trình gì nó không có ý thức được
đâu chỉ có mình ý này là kiểu
cách cách viết của cậu in Search thì da
mình mình có khi ở trên đường minh của
mình coi như là sao mà bạn không hiểu ý
của mình thì thôi câu này chắc à
anh sẽ chuyển qua câu thực hành bạn dễ
hình dung hơn sau tiếp cái câu a bạn trả
lời câu kia được
ở đâu
ở thời tiết tại sao lại thì em em nghĩ
thôi lưu câu này thì sẽ chưa tìm hiểu về
câu này thì em nghĩ là khi mà nó mang
đến bảo mật bởi vì nó nằm trong anh
à à
Ừ nó 500 rưỡi nhé
ừ ừ
Em thử thử như thế thử chơi câu khác
không Câu này có thể không nhớ có thể
chưa có khác
ví dụ là
Theo bạn thì có một cái gì nữa Nó cũng
có thể bảo mật
à mình mình dạy có một vài cái nó bảo
mật đấy mặt cho cho vợ à
à à
vì thế bạn không gian lận rồi thường
mình sẽ nếu không nhớ thì mình sẽ mở cái
linh linh tài liệu cũ lên đấy là da lợn
Ừ không sao như thế Chắc bạn phải gỡ
điểm bằng câu thực hành rồi Ok
có gì tí bạn ra lận mà xem lại các thứ
thứ rồi Trả lời câu thực hành em mình
nhá có thực hành của mình sẽ là tạo bố
sẽ lưu và
sự kỳ thị Da bạn lặp lại tài liệu mình
sẽ có có cái Ít ra đấy thì các bạn thì
bạn in sơ cho mình thử xem nhé
Okay tiếp theo thôi
Anh ở thì được ra các bạn không hẳn là
da lợn Nhưng mà thực ra trước mặt các
bạn là máy tính mà các bạn thể mở lên mà
Ừ tôi làm sao biết được điều đấy
thế là bạn à Bàn Văn Cường mà Văn Cường
vào đây mà
anh có đẹp Alo ạ Ok
lại luôn tiếp thị
I gose ở ngoại ô
à à
Ai có nhu cầu oxy effect II
khu
resort
thông cảm cho nếu mà các bạn thấy mình
vẫn đang làm hơi nông dân một tí vì mình
đang cảm thấy kéo
Thật ra hôm nay hơi gấp gấp ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok Gọi hai câu ngay gần nhau quá đẹp
luôn à
à à
Các bạn thấy câu hỏi
ở
hai câu Thầy vừa tra đúng ngoại
Nghe ca nhạc Tại sao mình lao đầu nó
ngọt đúng không
có thứ nhất là sự giống nhau giữa view
và Lysin có được hay là được nhau giữa
phân xưởng II
ừ ừ
ở đây thì có nghe không có có có
thế âm ly câu sự giống nhau giữa view
với
siêu gọi là
có điều à
tổ chức năng
em tắt
khi mà mình biết thì mình gọi ạ thì
không phải viết lại câu chuyện lần nữa
Nó giúp cho cái chương trình du lịch cái
lúc mình biên dịch và chạy nhanh hơn vì
lưu lại sẵn rồi đấy ạ
giúp cho bảo mật hơn
Ừ ừ
hết ở đông lại ạ
bài hát cơn đề ra sự giống nhau của view
với phom trơn á
Theo em là như vậy
Ừ thế thì ra có thiếu nhưng mà tiếp tiếp
chơi
con người giữa Oh Soo và ý thật sừng đi
ra
Á Đông
cho nhau à
ừ ừ
Ẩm Thực ra giống nhau thì cũng nghe nào
giống lúc này em thấy nó cứ lên nào
giống nhau mà khác nhau mỗi cái là mất
dần thì nó có thể trả về giá trị và kiểu
phát sinh thì không
không lòng người nhau được có xuyên thì
có thể lồng vào nhau được và tôi siêu
thì có thể gọi thì được phát sinh con
phát sinh Khi nhận không
số còn lại đi em thấy cũng chức năng
cũng na ná nhau
nhờ ân Pro thì
bạn hơn
em hết
ở sông hợp âm
đầu tiên về review phong trần thì giống
nhau nữa thì sẽ là
cả hai thằng đều đều trả về dữ liệu đều
dùng câu lệnh select để mặc gọi đúng
không ạ ạ
em
và nó hai thằng đấy cùng chỉ làm việc
được với ý đây QL tức là data quay
language các câu truy vấn đúng không
không không có câu
update Delete hay rớt thì cả đấy khác
nhau của nó thì phong trần thì truyền
được tham số vào để mà cậu các thứ còn
là vị bản chất view thì nó trẻ tạo ra
một bản kiểu gần nhất hợp một bàn rồi mà
tham chiếu đến cái thằng cha đúng không
nên thành ra nó không nó không chuyển
được cái gì cả
Ừ vợ
Anh ở hỏi câu cá nữa không ạ à
100 thì bạn làm à
cha làm cho mình view với phong trần đi
làm cho mình video for trên tạo tạo hai
câu
hai câu thực hành thế thôi đã lỡ cả con
phong trần với phong trần cũng thể gọi
lần này nhá quan tâm có thể gọi đến hoàn
thiện kia có
còn cái sự khác nhau giữa phong trần của
KOH được ra là mình có ghi ở trên đường
link của mình rồi đấy các bạn ấn vào bên
phongtrần sôi kéo xuống cuối này là nó
mình liệt kê đầy đủ tăng chân nó cả code
khác nhau Điểm gì ở đây rồi Các bạn cho
xem lại thôi ông ạ là
Ừ đúng rồi nói chuyện gì sẽ không Đây là
được
ờ ờ
Okay tiếp theo nhỉ Bạn kia vừa nhắc mình
thì da mình thể copy từ đoạn này mình
quên mình bảo ở bây giờ mình đang ở Vịnh
áo Xin lỗi các bạn
ờ ờ tiếp theo là bạn
cô Trần Thị Linh Phương bạn con gái thế
Các Bạn Phương còn em
Ê Phương có về on rất sớm không biết có
lên tiền không
à
Dạ có thầy
Phương Linh 2 Minh Phương
Lê
Minh Cường
kệ tờ có hỏi của bạn đấy à
à à
anh Mạnh thiệu Dịch câu Mặt Trời ạ
Lê
Minh Phương ơi à
em dịch câu hỏi làn điệu
câu đầu cô đầu
có câu đàn nói
câu đầu nào
có bao nhiêu lệnh không biết là lệnh
đúng không nói như vậy có thể thực hiện
được và trong một cuốn CPU ở
đoạn dịch bao nhiêu
đồng đội sẽ điều thị ở Ý là hỏi đã có
thể dùng được DL với lại dml ạ
ở
câu thứ hai là so sánh cái giá trị trả
về giữa phân xưởng seaview II
cho anh cần cái
phần sân Thì mình bắt buộc phải trả về
một cái giá trị
cho con con nào
câu đấy tôi số bao nhiêu ạ
Dạ
Con thật sự bao nhiêu ạ
đang ở
à lạnh chả nhớ nó có dù có nhiều lắm để
mình xem lại à
à à
à à câu này Hóa ra em chưa em chưa chuẩn
bị
Ô
kìa Cái fan sân Thì bắt buộc phải trả về
một giá trị còn tôi sẽ đi thì nó sẽ có
thể trả về một giá trị hoặc là trả về
một cái bảng không bắt buộc à
Ừ
Ok bạn ạ ạ
Xin chào Đấy Thế cũng được rồi không ạ ạ
ờ ờ
để mình mình xưởng chút
đó là cái câu kia không phải là bao
nhiêu loại lệnh được sử dụng trong ODA
mà là
khả năng có có thể ghi được bao nhiêu
lần tất cả ám chỉ là ghi được bao nhiêu
lệnh cũng được ấy và thời gian đấy mà
bạn nói mỗi ddl3 đến bây giờ thì vẫn
thiếu nó vẫn còn là đây QL nặng là cầu
select này
ngài Nói sông à à
cô bé cũng tương đối ổn rồi nhìn thấy
thế thì bây giờ thì bạn tra bài tập của
bạn cũng sẽ làm tạo cho mình một phong
trần và một tôi sẽ đi nhé
con dê chi tiết ý là tạo cái gì cũng
được à chọn gì cũng được chấm dựa theo
cái đấy dạng hơn các bạn muốn tâm sự
anh đợi mình tắt máy của bạn ạ Hơi bị rè
mình thì xin lỗi các bạn
Các bạn có thể nghe giọng con gái vẽ hay
nhưng ạ Nó bị rè mình mình đang đeo tai
nghe hơi bị chó ăn thịt à
thì các bạn muốn được điểm cao rõ ràng
nãy giờ mình đang đề kháng năm ở ấy và
các bạn muốn nước điểm cao thì các bạn
có để ý cái đường link của mình có câu
hỏi mở rộng đâu em ạ Các bạn sẽ
em muốn điểm cao thì các bạn sẽ làm cái
thực hành có có một trong những cái này
thì các bạn có thể tra bây giờ làm Nếu
cứ tra mời bắt đầu tra thì có thể không
kịp vào nhau mà các bạn nếu mà biết qua
cái này rồi tốt các bạn sẽ làm thêm
những cái kiểu nâng cao Thêm một tí
không ạ Không chỉ câu y rất đơn giản hai
câu tạo phụ cô sẽ đưa đơn giản có thứ
thứ
anh cảm nhận được xem phải rất là cao
nhưng mà tôi thấy tôi để cho mấy ông một
cái pho mở kia nhưng mấy ông không điền
con vì vậy tôi mới thấy có đúng với 7
ông Điền à Còn mỗi mà bạn nữa này bạn
tên là hen à
các bạn có đây không
khi sex
à Dạ có Ok em
Ừ Ok bạn ạ Đây Câu hỏi tiếp theo của bạn
đây
Ê còn nhiều câu hỏi mãi mà Mấy ông không
ngon
Ừ Ok
hai cái này có vệ từ đối dễ này à
Âm Nhạc
Anh
có bao nhiêu cách truyền tham số khi tạo
thủ tục đúng không thấy
Ừ
đúng rồi thế ghế hạnh phúc đọc hàng Phố
Cydia không cần dịch thủ tục rồi ok ở
Ừ thì em hiện tại em đang nghĩ ta có rất
nhiều
[âm nhạc]
nhưng mà nó đang là kiểu gì thật
à mà không cái câu ngày thực ra nó hơi
bị
mình thấy do dịch như thế nhưng Thành A
nó hơi bị tống nghĩa nhỉ ờ ờ
Vì vậy bây giờ Hỏi hỏi na ná công tương
tự đi theo bạn thì bode có truyền được
tham số 20 và tham số
nếu mà nếu mà truyền hàm số thì có chữ
hợp nào có thể hiểu để mặc định ngoại lệ
được không hay bắt buộc phải chuyển 5 số
ừ ừ
ê ê
ở phố cebu thì có thể truyền tham số có
thể
à mà còn mất tính thì em nghĩ là vẫn có
thể cho nun được thôi ạ
em có cho nó mua cái mặc định được đúng
không giả vờ một con không nhập
cho iPhone
a Cho mạch điện thật về một lần luôn à
cho con cái thứ hai là
bộ phim sex tự ý
ở
shop em
viết tắt của thủ tục và biểu tượng sau
là thực hiện
thì lập blog người đó nghề ạ
ưu đãi
Asaki viết tắt nó là như thế nào
và thực hiện nào không biết viết tắt nó
nghỉ à
anh ơi
à à
em không có biết cái này luôn nghỉ à
cho Android bạn bảo Crop thì đúng rồi
đúng không ở như thế này con ếch skill
thì cũng còn ít thật đấy là thực hiện
của người Việt ta chả có
mày không đi trả lời xin lỗi
nói sách rồi mà đúng không Thì hiểu vợ ạ
Cái gì à
access đúng
thực ra thì mình cần nói rồi Nếu mà mấy
cái từ dài quá cái tắt nó sẽ ra bốn từ
câu này hơi dễ nhưng mà nhưng mà bài tập
của bạn này sẽ là
tạo của CPU này và và sẽ bao gồm cả bạn
tham số mặc định và tham số truyền vào
bắt buộc
bạn thử làm mình gọi
ở ngoài keo Giọng ông ai châm ok
à à
vì vậy hết hết những người hỏi rồi a đây
thêm một ông nữa người không Hoàng Trọng
Nhất
các bạn sẽ nhất có đem ạ ạ
à à
anh alo alo Hỏi trọng nhất rồi
Chỉ có những người ở đây chị nghe thôi
mà
thì
các bạn Hòa trọng nhất mà vừa điền form
các bạn Nhật Hoàng không ạ
Nhà
bạn ở đâu mở mic hả
à à
à
À đây bạn Hoàng Hoàng Nhất đây đúng
không ạ
nữ hoàng Bí Thư à
em ở quá đen đó bạn rồi
à à
ừ ừ
Ở đây câu hỏi của bạn đây Bạn trả bạn
trả lời trong che vậy nhé sau đó thì bậy
à
anh
Alo ạ
anh alo alo Adele câu hỏi của bạn đây
Bạn tra bạn trả lời chính xác về nhá sau
đó thì mày à
các
bạn đã tắt Để em YouTube alo alo alo
alo alo alo bạn dịch câu hỏi không nghe
đây Alo Alo ạ
anh alo alo alo alo
em không nghe luôn rồi đó
Sao
tưởng mình à
Mở mic không nghe
Ừ thôi cứ trả lời câu hỏi đi
[âm nhạc]
nghe không được
ừ Địt gái à
anh alo
anh alo alo
anh Alo ạ
à à
tôi
bắt đầu thấy giống thầy Hiệu phó ạ
anh alo alo
anh Alo ạ
anh alo alo bên A bên mix em không nghe
được
không Sao bạn sẽ trả lời cho ông nghe
được nữa rồi
à mà nó trả lời câu hỏi đi
Bây giờ em nghe được anh em nhỉ Ok rồi à
em có nè
Cái này à
à à
ở cột nào của bảng là prospects Ở đây có
amply sẽ nạp
iPhone là có Sa Đéc
nâng ghost.exe sẽ là
của nó sẽ là music remix Ai là việc
không non rất mendes à
Ừ ừ
So sánh sự giống nhau và khác nhau của
unix và ranicki thì Real Madrid là
Ừ bắt lô nắp luôn không có lời remix thì
Campuchia chủ yếu là để khóa chính
ý
là cái chung là không gặp lại và
mà không có nôn thì Yoona có thể luôn
Anh remix có thể luôn nữa thì nó là sự
khác biệt của nói với bao nhiêu kỳ
ở nhà em nghĩ vậy
Ừ Ok bạn trả lời
đúng sách giáo khoa II
cả hai con này có vẻ liên quan thì nhau
vậy nha tốt phết ờ
em gọi mày qua tôi đợi mãi có một ông có
Index tôi chỉ có đề bài cho ông đơn giản
thôi
ông in xuất cho tôi tầm 1 triệu bản ghi
đánh lên tách cho bạn đầy
A và để mà xem tốc độ khi mà trước khi
đánh Index của sau khi đánh Nhưng đấy
thì tốc độ rồi Như nào
ông nữa ông sẽ phải ghi tôi cái câu in
sớm mà trợ bạn ghi rồi tôi nhá Cái gì
không chịu ghi Ok
con đơn giản mà
ủi xe
mày không học lập trình rồi Mày không
phải tự ứng biến vụ đây đi
ok à
ở dạ dày thời tiếp tiếp con ông nào nữa
Đỗ Thị thanhthi cuối cùng đã lên tiếng
chuông ạ bạn Đỗ Thị Ôn thi có đây em ạ
nhà có
mic bạn này cô về cụ ông cùng bạn kia
OK đợi tí là đủ cầu họ đã
à à
khi
đặt câu hỏi đấy ạ
ừ ừ
à à
hai
câu đầu tiên là có thể sử dụng
một cái lạnh để gọi thủ tục hoặc loại
hoặc là đúng mà
bạn chị lại mà là câu đầu tiên cá thể là
có thể sử dụng cái lệnh để gọi mưa đi
hoặc là phân xanh đúng không ạ lệnh lệnh
gì cơ ạ
bộ phim
để dành cho coi lên cho em ạ
[âm nhạc]
à à
khi bạn trả lời có ý xem
anh
em tí em rồi à
Ừ ông xã Bình tĩnh à
à à
Ê mấy ông kia bình luận gì đó để cho bạn
ấy phấn chấn hơn đi
thì tại sao nhắc em gái tự nhiên giờ xem
băng Anh Kiệt chưa rồi
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ không thì trả lời câu câu thứ hai
trước định Hưởng Ánh Sáng
ông Dương Văn nghệ qua câu 2 chúa à
à à
sau
khi loại bỏ một cái bảng có liên quan
tới màu nêu
có một bản có cái quần Rồi liên quan các
bạn đó thì cái thủ tục Vẫn còn tồn tại
bị xóa thì nó vẫn không tồn tại khi mà
mình xóa đi cái bảng đó
khi chạy theo bạn thì những cái gì mình
đã học
bạn bạn thử liệt kê cho mình những ngày
thơ Mình đã học được
trong cài yeah trên so với
về phần mình hôm qua những đề danh mục
vừa rồi
là mình để kêu mấy cái đại học ở đây
không
ai
Có code ở đúng không còn gì nữa
fashion chích girl and với view
Viettel bạn thì những cái nào thì khi mà
xóa bảng thì nó sẽ được sò Theo
em nghĩ là em bé hả à
ở Iraq này còn gì nữa
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ nếu trường hợp view mà nó sẽ rách cái
bảng 1 bảng đó thì xóa cái bà kia review
bị xóa đi theo
tình
yêu không bị xóa nhưng mà kêu mà mình
gọi nó sẽ bị lỗi rồi mà vẫn tình bạn
nhiều đấy đúng không Ok Thế còn là chị
cờ ạ Chị giờ thì sao ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này không nhớ đi cho con cò đấy nó
nó đó là on trên bàn làm như bà nào Xóa
Xóa đi Con ngựa chứng ơi nó sẽ xóa theo
còn mỗi vô Cydia thì như bạn vừa nói nó
sẽ không xóa Vì thời gian nó độc lập nó
hôm nay còn Nó là kiểu trái ngoan bàn
nào cả Có mắm mì khi chạy lại thì cha nó
giống Lưu nó sẽ bảo lỗi bản chất cái
view từ ra bởi vì nó cũng do nó nối nhờ
bạn quá mình lỗi Theo bạn thì còn phòng
chơi này ra à
à à
I phân xanh thì nó vẫn còn vẫn còn à
Ừ
đấy thì nó tương tự view đúng không
Ok Thế còn câu một tự tin trả lời chưa
101 trả lời xong mấy hôm qua nhất cho 10
hết
ừ ừ
- 1 thìa nhớ tách nó làm hai cái đầu
tiên thì cho hay có gọi được Toshiba
không à
anh ạ
à à
Khi bạn mất đi đâu vậy
cái này không nhớ
rồi có gọi được phong chân cong Theo bạn
có gọi không
à à
anh cứ trời Mạnh Mạnh dạn lên có sao đâu
Xin chào lấy được thì tự nhiên được cộng
điểm không được khi mình cũng lo mất
điểm đâu đúng không
ừ ừ
hỗ
trợ run rẻ Ok Thật ra là cái này cách để
mà trả lời thì mình hiểu được bản chất
được hai cái thằng ngu thì thứ nhất là
nó gọi từ check Mai nó gọi bằng Excel
Kill đúng không bà Thật ra thì giống như
vừa nãy Phương Linh Phương Linh như vậy
Trả lời cái Woa đã gạt phăng chân giống
nhau có thể trả lời cục dữ liệu thực ra
thì cái đấy nó không đúng lắm bởi vô sẽ
như bản chất mà không trả về dữ liệu chị
in dữ liệu thôi tăng trần nó mới có trả
về dữ liệu cụ thể có thể trả về bạn và
cài cho ấy chỉ roi nó chỉ do được với
bạn thôi thành ra nó cho mỗi khoanh chân
chứ nó không vào được boot đây tới để
các bạn hiểu được cái đấy thì trả lời
được mấy câu kiểu như thế này ví dụ dạng
cái này tương tự thế giống như là select
có gọi được phong phong trần nhưng mà sẽ
lấy không gọi được cô sẽ lưu vì bản chất
for you nó sẽ không trả về dữ liệu mà
chúng ngon nhưng không sẽ lách người à à
Ừ ok
thì bạn làm cho mình à
đi câu hỏi đề cập bố review nhiều nhé
ạ Bây giờ bạn làm cho mình một cái cô sẽ
lưu và gọi phương trình trong đấy đi
nghĩa là vẫn phải tạo một phần chân họ
thận chứ tạo luôn phong trần Trong OXY
cũng được ok được ạ Vâng ạ ok
Ừ ông kia vẫn 10 điểm ông sim Ok Thật ra
không biết được buổi này nó
chắc là buổi này cũng sắp kết thúc của
mình không biết được buổi này kiểu bao
lâu nữa Nếu mấy ông tranh thủ đăng ký
hỏi tiếp mà Tôi thấy hết hết sư người
rồi tại sao tôi ngay cái Star hiển thị
lên này không
Ừ hình như là do cái tiện ích này của
tôi nó đang tự động bấm cái gì đó rồi
a-class đã
ừ ừ
có
tổng cộng có đường mỗi chín bạn trả lời
câu hỏi
ừ ừ
Ừ cái thế
à à
ăn mít à mít mình xem có bị giới hạn
thời gian mà mình mình mời mình xem nó
bị nó bảo thế mà mít Limit này
thì lúc đấy mình cha lí mít với giun Cái
rét run này nó bảo là gồm ít thì bị giới
hạn
ở đây
giun thì chỉ được 40 phút nữa miễn phí
Này 100 người này còn mít thì ạ Chỉ yêu
một tiếng group mình không biết group nó
là gì Chắc là có khi mình mình không
phải group nên thành nam như thế
I am ido imandu gần đây Mình có đăng ký
ở nhưng mà cái này là nó liên quan Quốc
xây cái gì đó
Ừ chứ không không
a Google Now free
vì chúng mình không rõ lắm nhưng mà nó
bảo là cứ
đến đến gần hết rồi 5 phút thì nó mới
bắt đầu cảnh báo mình cơ có vẻ nãy giờ
chưa cảnh báo thì mình cứ chuyển tiếp
rồi
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Microsoft âm nhưng mà
Microsoft shopping của lăng nhăng thì da
mình định bảo các bạn sang discourse cơ
nhưng mà đi code thì được là có phải bạn
biết mình qua kênh YouTube và discord mà
nó bị đóng em thành ra là
thì mình gọi điện cho thầy hiệu trưởng
nhưng mà thấy hiệu trưởng đang đi ngủ
rồi không biết em đi ngủ hay à Hai nóc
nhà
trong nhà cầm sử điện thoại
ừ ừ
Ừ ok Nói chung là mấy ông không đăng ký
thêm cái for mà tôi có kim với phom đấy
mày ông không đang tận vừa rồi lễ 135
người xem
vì thế mà cuối cùng thì chẳng ông nào
hỏi thêm gì hay để thi và đáp mình tôi
tự hỏi từ trả lời nhé
Ê mày xử cho hỏi cậu sạch à
à à
em lấy bạn ở đây có muốn chia sẻ thì ông
đây Đang nó tranh thủ
các bạn các bạn Đấy muốn chia sẻ gì
không ạ
Em có phải bạn rồi ra ngon mà chưa sẻ
tâm sự vậy
thì các bạn ấy muốn chia sẻ thì không ạ
Em muốn chia sẻ
ông không muốn trả lời mọi nguồn chia sẻ
à à Ừ vợ
Ừ ok chọi chồng chưa về à
tỷ
lệ quy rồi
Ừ Ok vợ xong chưa rảnh
à Dạ em xin hỏi là còn thi là nữa không
ạ ngay em vào muộn mất một tiếng
hỗ
trợ vẫn được thi mà bạn Điền cho mày kho
mà Thì Thôi
ở
đời bạn sẽ được vào hàng ưu tiên ở có
mỗi mình bạn ạ
ừ ừ
anh em muốn nghe chị Phương Linh chưa rẻ
Ừ Ok hay
à à
bài hát Alo đêm ở lại mấy giây ớt nhưng
nãy giờ nếu không nghe được
Em à bây giờ mở mic trên YouTube mà à
anh alo alo
ờ ờ
các bạn Vũ Duy nhiên kia có thể trả lời
trả lời vượt đam không mình trả lời hay
hay là chỉ muốn chia sẻ thôi Chứ rẻ thì
mở mic nên chia sẻ cũng được
anh chia sẻ về cái gì cũng được
chia sẻ về kiểu điều tra của liên hoan
một tí là liên quan đến việc mà dụ
một tờ liên quan đến nhóm you tim này
những quan đến ngành ngay tin này chẳng
án liên quan đến Đi do mà bạn hôm nay tự
nhiên và có mặt ở đây không
khi mở
tạo Vậy thì à
Anh đợi em chút
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ chắc thôi để thật tại em nhé Em hơi bị
nhát
Ok ah
từ ngày hôm kiểu này thì ra giờ rồi Hôm
nay thật là bảo thì vẫn đáp Qua Thế thì
còn đáp lại cho người ông quen việc à
đây không hẳn là tính là nói trước đám
đông rồi ca tôi không bắt máy Ông kiểu
khoe mặt như là không có người nào trước
mặt mấy ông bà đúng không ạ
a baby chắc ra Cũng khiến nó Tôi đỡ run
thế tôi mà vừa trước làm đông các thứ
tôi run lắm rồi sẽ run hơn Bây giờ nhiều
ạ
à à
Anh ở bạn thành Nguyễn Đức chia sẻ đi
đúng không
các bạn có mở máy điện thoại
à à
ở những câu hỏi của các bạn Hôm nay chắc
làm xin phép ra là để buổi lùn rồi sau
như em nói không ạ Ok Ok giọng ngọt ngấm
dậm châm phát biểu gì bạn sử
anh alo Ok bạn Bạn nói đi em Em vừa tắt
mất cái
mất cái top này em không nên thấy khi
kiểu uống em chia sẻ là tại vì sau khi
em
học được ở em đi làm được một chút chút
để em thầy thì em có thấy là mọi người
nếu mà có cái thức một chút rồi thì hãy
mạnh dạng đi xin thực tập thực tập sớm
sớm vào kiếm được nhiều kinh nghiệm mà
nghe
sứ không cần phải quá cầu toàn rồi
Kiểu cần nhiều kiến thức gì vậy rồi mới
đi tập nghe em em thấy nhiều khi thấy
hơi thường em ạ
à à
ờ ờ Bạn nói rất đúng kiểu thực ra là cái
quan trọng vẫn là tự tin cái thứ thứ và
3 trạm sớm đúng không
Nghe ca nhạc
nhưng mà nay sự chết của đây ạ
các bạn bạn bạn thể chia sẻ thêm dù bạn
đang theo ngày nào bạn ạ
đang đang vàng đi học hay đã đi làm rồi
thực tập như nào cũng được dạ thì thì em
có cũng học công nghệ thông tin em cũng
mới đi làm được 22 tháng đẹp
are you
Ừ thì em Thế em ạ
Anh bắt đầu đi làm thì em chuyển sang
boss hết thì thấy thì nó cũng hơi khác
một xíu
nhưng mà em thấy học được qua cái lớp
này em học được nhiều thể Quá nhiều luôn
ừ ừ
các bạn nếu Thế bạn đi đi làm ở đi thực
tập rồi hay là đi làm hẳn chứng trước
rồi là vậy sợ em vẫn đang đi thực tập
thì vẫn gọi là thực tập và à
Đại Nghĩa là các bạn thấy rõ ràng có một
bạn thực tập bạn vẫn có thể lên đây nói
lại chia sẻ các thứ thứ không ạ Chứ
không phải cậu loài người yêu cờ toàn
mình ông nhiều năm kinh nghiệm rồi lên
đây loài không ạ
tượng vườn
Ừ
mình đi thực tập mà mình vừa vào 54 mà ạ
Ừ Ok Thế bạn học đại học chính quy kẹo
54535 4 mới bắt đầu đi sự thật ngon
bạn thể chia sẻ ví dụ là kiểu baby Mình
nãy giờ mình đang cố hạn chế việc là nói
về năm tuổi 72 cũng như là chia sẻ thông
thông tin cá nhân kiểu giống như học ở
trường nào thì bỏ qua mấy vụ đấy nhưng
bạn đánh giá thế nào So việc là không
không phải do mình với trên trường mà
nói trên trường đấy bạn đánh giá kiểu
trường dạy bạn cảm thấy khó hiểu hay
không Hay là cách cái thực học tập của
bạn như thế nào
để ra thì nếu mà so với ở trường cái này
thì kiến thức ở trường nó nếu mà mọi
người mà không
không làm luôn không làm ở dự không ăn
làm những cái dự án nhỏ của riêng mình
thì em nghĩ là một tháng hoặc thậm chí
là một vài tuần là quê luôn nè Ừ
tại vì nhắn thì kiến thức vì nó không
như thầy không không không không nên so
sánh mình sẽ lại họp gạo và mình nó kéo
nó có những từ nó kéo dài hơi như hơi bị
quái này à
anh em thấy về mà bây giờ thì khi đi làm
thì cái tính quan trọng nhất là tính tự
học không về
ừ ừ
các bạn này có vẻ có có triển vọng nhà
máy ông nhỉ Tôi cảm thấy kiểu từng yêu
tí là triển vọng ở đây ngoài việc bỏ qua
với giọng nói nhá
cái tự tin bỏ qua mấy cái yếu tố đấy mà
cái việc là
bạn ấy trên vọng việc bạn ấy cũng đang
hình dung được định hướng và thư mục
tiêu rõ ràng rồi Nhà bạn cậu Nghĩa triển
vọng ít nhất là bạn ấy không bỏ ngày nay
cậu thấy ngày ngày phù hợp với mình đúng
không Nhưng mà có những bạn ở đây có thể
chat hay không như bạn theo kiểu là đến
buổi hôm nay rồi vẫn cảm thấy mùng lung
vẫn cảm thấy chưa
anh vẫn kẹo nửa chân thì bước vào nửa
chân thì ở trên bờ với kiểu của thế vẫn
còn run không dám bước hẳn xuống ạ
Thì em thấy thì mọi người cứ thoải mái
thôi đã xác định thì cứ thế mà mà làm
thôi hả
anh không đấy để giàu là mình mình đang
có thể bạn có thể giống mình là thì cậu
là không bị tác động bởi môi trường xung
quanh giờ bố mẹ thì thợ tạo điều kiện
chẳng hạn thế xong rồi sau đó đi
mình không bị áp lực về kinh tế chẳng
hạn mình Mình có quen vài bạn là kiểu
bởi vì nghe nghĩa vụ là đi tập không
lương này hay các kiểu như bạn đấy Kiểu
đang học nói trường mà cũng phải đi làm
việc khác để ạ kiểu trả tiền học luôn
đấy Nãy giờ kiểu Thành ra bạn đấy Quá
thời gian
học thời gian làm quá rồi gian học bạn
ấy cậu bị mất nguồn gốc bởi vì cái ngành
này còn phải tự học đấy mà đúng không
Không có thời gian tự học thì mất dần
gốc nhanh lắm
Ừ đúng rồi mẹ
em mà Bây giờ em thấy làm gì có thực tập
công lương nó đâu thầy xong thì nó chỉ
trợ cấp thôi mà sợ ở gần lượng cao kiểu
mới mới vào thì trợ cấp Mức tương đối
thành ra kiểu không không bằng những cái
ngành khác kiểu lao động chân tay thì
chỉ cần một vài ngày làm được việc xong
rồi lương cũng tương đồng luôn đấy à
ờ ờ có bạn Cường Nguyễn cũng muốn chia
sẻ kìa thì
các bạn cứ mở Mic lên chia sẻ thôi
chị đánh nhau
tai nghe thấy tiếng Anh chưa Ok ok rồi
Vâng
thì thì hôm nay em cứ ngỡ hiện là anh là
Cường lại ở học sinh em cái cũng không
ngại là chia sẻ về mấy thứ liên quan đến
bản thân đâu nên là em sẽ công khai luôn
cũng được không nhưng mà ý tôi là nên
giàu đi không phải để kiểu bởi vì kiểu
nó còn liên quan yếu tố là là
không không phải ngại cả mà liên quan gì
tối là mình là mình ở đây một cộng đồng
đa dạng ấy cùng đó là mình chỉ nói về
ngành nghề thôi chứ mình nó Cụ thể một
người đó thì giống như là một người đại
diện cả có thể cái cũng tốt
thì
em
tự xưng hô ở dưới đây à áo kiểu
em xin phép gọi thầy là thầy Tại vì thấy
chắc là cũng nhớ em nhé Tại vì em hãy
quay hỏi trên kia treo rồi thấy khó mà
mình nhớ bạn mà ba ẩn Xem xem đi Xem lại
video mình so với hỏi cũng cũng dài dài
phết
lên rất là khó kích là em muốn gọi được
thầy thầy anh thay vì anh ạ
Bởi vì bởi vì em là
sinh viên năm 2 đại học à
Ê
cho hỏi trường em không học được mấy bây
giờ em toàn đi được học thôi giờ sau khi
bất cứ sự nào mấy giờ Bây giờ là buổi
cuối đúng không ạ Nên nở Nhưng mà thực
sự bây giờ em mới học xong cái single
after của thầy cũng chưa đến cái buổi
hôm nay ạ ngân hàng mà hôm nay em đi
Thấy thứ bảy cuối nhưng mà em cũng muốn
tâm sự với thai 13 nhiều ạ
các
bạn bạn cứ nói đi
Ừ
thì
thật sự là từ hồi lên đại học đến nói
ở sau song phải ngắn nhất của em là thật
sự là phải gần đây em có học được nhiều
kiến thức trên trường kiềm ở nó rất là
đâu Kiểu 15 buổi mỗi môn Mỗi môn học là
15 buổi 15 buổi tương ứng với đúng 15
tuần thì đó
Ừ thì mất ta buổi để thi thi và giấy
giới thiệu rồi và còn Vậy là còn 12 buổi
và 12 buổi này kiến thức mà rất là chung
chung lúc nó không nó không không
không hiểu tức là nó đi theo kiểu là tụi
mình cứ nữa cho hoa thì không tập trung
vào một cái vấn đề cụ thể nào đó nó họ
rất thầy dạy rất là
À thầy thầy dạy rất là kiểu nào
ẩm
thực tế hơn đúng không em cửa là mình
mình mình mình hiểu ý bạn hiểu bản chất
là mấy cái buổi học đấy ý làm cho mình
cảm thấy mông lung hơn mình càng lòng
mình càng mu lông là cậu không biết ở
học xong cái này mình sẽ làm cái gì nữa
mình thực hành như thế nào Vân
Bởi vì bởi vì kích thước này nó rất là
rộng như là
nhưng mà cắt hơi nó cũng thấy thời không
đi xong rồi một và nêu cụ thể mãi cứ đi
chân Liên ra tự học nhưng mà Từ khi gặp
được được thấy em cảm thấy là thầy thầy
rất là thầy đã biết ra là biết cách dẫn
dắt sinh
ta sự không thể nói được Nhưng mà em
nghĩ là hình tĩnh nữa thì em hơi run
anh Linh mình hiểu ý bạn thì ra mình
cũng run mà
kiểu
thực ra thì
chắc chắc là các bạn ở đây muốn tâm sự
chia sẻ mấy cái kiểu đấy cũng nhiều tra
bạn đang đại diện nói cho vài bạn đấy
nhưng mà
như mình nói và mấy ông kia cũng đang
bình luận về việc bán tự vi sư án nhất
nhất tự vi sư bán tự vi sư thì mình đã
từng nói vụ và mình lại vụ nát đến thầy
bởi vì thầy với mình thì nó vẫn là gì đó
Thiên Thiên Lương và nó là một cái mức
tiêu chuẩn giữa sáng mình thì
ở ngoài đời ca mình vẫn như thế này mình
nghĩ gì Nói Đấy mình kiểu Sống ngay
thẳng kiểu thế nên mới mới mạnh mồm được
không ạ Nhưng mà chắc chả ra mình cũng
đầy ta xấu nên thành ra mình không muốn
các bạn kiểu con mình một tấm gương sáng
rồi sụp đổ khi mà thấy mình có thật xấu
gì gì đó Đang sử ở trên này mình không
văng tục em ạ nhưng ngoài đời mình có
văng tục mình có chửi bậy chửi bậy không
vậy chửi câu nào cũng chửi nhưng mà vẫn
là có chửi bà hoặc à mình cũng có một
vài cái mặt xấu à Không ăn mặc xấu nữa
mặc tối
số bưởi à mặt mà tối hoàn toàn luôn mình
mà chia sẻ ở đây chắc ạ là nó là một vài
phút theo kiểu là mình sẽ không ngừng
mắt lên lực nữa Đồng Nghĩa lên đấy Mình
không nói quá đâu Hiến Thành ơi mình rất
ngại vụ vì sau sẽ có ai đó bóc phốt cái
đấy của mình thì cái từ thầy thì nó sẽ
bị bị kiểu bị lỏng ngược hoàn toàn thì
mình sẽ rất kỹ từ thời đấy
tự nhiên về sau tự nhận hình cái vụ phốt
Thầy nghĩ Long rồi abc.xyz 15 để giới
hạn trên scale cái bài báo này nó thì
xảy ra
nhưng mình hiểu ý bạn đó là mình mình
đang làm một người chia sẻ các thứ thứ
tạo động lực truyền cảm hứng các bạn
quan qua những cái này và đặc biệt là
miễn phí cho ngồi dễ mình mình Nghĩa
dùng từ dễ tiếp cận cho các bạn để các
bạn kiểu cảm thấy là nó đỡ khó khăn hơn
trong việc học ở chiến trường gì đó đúng
không ạ Ừ nó bộ trợ gì đó
cho
nên là mình mình cảm thấy ở các bạn kiểu
thực ra các bạn có thể không không hạt
nào kiểu cần cảm ơn hay là thậm chí
có bạn bảo đã gửi mình cái gì đó Vân Vân
mình chả mình không không cần và hơi
ngại mấy cái vụ đấy hơi lại luôn đấy bởi
vì như mình đã nói mình còn bị về vụ là
thu tiền hai cái gì đó có việc việc liên
quan đến vật chất hay ở liên quan đến
những cái mà các bạn
anh chọn báo đáp lại cho mình có gì đó
là mình cảm thấy mình cũng đang nghe máy
nợ các bạn Vậy mà em mình bị ngại luôn ở
bộ đấy nên là mình đang làm với tư cách
là đam mê thôi các bạn ạ cho các bạn đi
thì mình cũng luôn nhận lại được cái sự
thoải mái vui vẻ khi mà các bạn cảm thấy
hài lòng với nó đúng ạ chính mình như
thế thôi
ừ ừ
à à
Các bạn có muốn chia sẻ gì thêm không ạ
Em định chia sẻ hơi Cá nhân đôi chút
nhưng mà thầy cho tụi kia vừa lúc đầu
thầy nói nói Đây là kiểu tập thể là em
không muốn biết cô giáo chia sẻ làm gió
ờ ờ
ừ nếu thế thì sao các bạn có thể nhắn
tin chia sẻ với mình thực ra mình đang
định nói là sắp đến 20 tháng 11
3000 nói thế điểm này ông chuẩn bị tặng
hoa thôi đâu nhé
mà mà
mà mình nghĩ là các bạn nên giống mình
đó là nhắn tin cho các thầy cô của mình
không phải những thầy cô trên trường
luôn mà giống ngờ mình có có hai người
thầy đầu đời một người thầy là
dạy mình ảo thuật thôi nhưng mà cũng cậu
là một con người gương mẫu liêm chính
đấy mới đúng là một người thầy đối với
mình bởi vì cậu sẽ là
liêm khiết các thứ thứ
mình sẽ nhắn tin cậu thường ai chúc mấy
người đấy và cậu nói chung là chia sẻ
cảm nghĩ mình thôi đúng ạ tha thứ và một
người thầy nữa là người thầy khi mà mình
đi thực tập mình đi làm thì người người
chúc đựng mình hàng ngày mình hỏi mình
hỏi hơn các bạn nhiều ạ thì các bạn rất
nhiều hỏi liên tục hàng ngày mà đi
ở đây thì mình nghĩa là các bạn sẽ nên
cầm tìm những cái người xung quanh mình
là coi những người ấy là người thầy thực
sự không cần mình dạy học như này mới là
thầy đúng không ạ
chị sẽ các bạn kiểu học hỏi những người
xung quanh các thứ thứ
Ừ vợ Tại vì ngay từ lúc đầu em vào hết
em đã giới thiệu bản thân của mình và
anh đã giấy thầy thực hiện giới hạn
mười cái kiểu ấy hát tên với cả trường
là em là hơi run rồi nha cũng không dám
chia sẻ kỹ hơn nên là sau buổi học này
em muốn nói chuyện với thầy nghiệm nhiều
hơn nữa điều em muốn lấy chút kinh
nghiệm của này à các bạn hoàn toàn nhắn
tin được cho mình nhé các bạn nếu mà các
bạn thử nhắn tin rồi mới thấy mình làm
con người dễ dãi như nào khi mà ai mình
trả lời kể cả người ghét mình chửi mình
mình cũng trả lời rồi ra tại mình không
bơ được họ mình hơi bị hạn chế điểm Đấy
là kiểu thực ra là mình đã phải bơ những
cái người nào mà không quan trọng lắm ý
nghĩa em sẽ không không không đem lại
cho mình thì lợi ích gì em ạ dụng là
mình chửi nhau mình còn sẽ làm chửi nhau
với một người tay bo cơ thể qua mạng
chẳng hạn như kiểu bị trẻ trâu ấy à Ô
thế không tốt nhưng mà hiểu bởi vì mình
không không chịu được thì việc đấy
Nhắn tin qua mọi mọi kênh từ bình luận ở
đây bạn Cường Nguyễn này bình luận ở
trên kênh YouTube mình nhé đấy chẳng ăn
hoặc nhắn tin qua Facebook hay discord
đủ thể loại mấy ông thật chị gửi mail
tục trả lời sẽ thế
nào ạ Em cảm ơn thầy ạ
Ừ đúng rồi gọi bằng thầy còn tạo ra
khoảng cách nữa đúng không ạ Bạn kia nói
đúng đấy Đó là mình mình bảo rồi các bạn
coi mình như tiền bối đi trước thôi đó
là có thứ gì cảm thấy học hỏi được thì
học hỏi còn những thứ gì mà cảm thấy hư
hỏng quá thì nên né hơn là cậu thấy mình
là tấm gương về học hỏi thế hết thì hỏng
ấy ạ
anh không lại bảo tôi đầu tiên mệt lắm à
ở sông kia nói có một ông nói đúng vụ
tôi bị sao đấy
à à
thì
các bạn hỏi về mọi Cảnh được hỏi không
phải mỗi về về học tập nhé tôi tôi bảo
tôi cái gì tội sẵn sàng chia sẻ được mấy
cái nhạy cảm tôi vừa nói thì có thể tôi
sẽ tùy từng người dân chia sẻ nhưng mà
còn những cái kiểu
tâm tư tình cảm thương sẵn trả lời được
tôi từng tôi từng mấy lần chia sẻ mấy
ông cách để mà hiểu được con gái
sắp ăn món gì hay gì gì đó Xẽ nhãn thì
cái đấy chắc là tôi sẽ xài được
bí quyết tự tin ở tôi sẽ làm huấn luyện
viên không mấy ông rồi việc à không phải
mỗi mấy mấy bạn nam mà cả mấy bạn nữ nữa
nó tôi tôi tự tin là tôi sẽ không huấn
luyện viên rồi cho các bạn thì tôi từng
ra sân khá nhiều rồi
à à
anh
chia sẻ tool tán gái à
cho
tôi tôi tôi Hiệp gọi tôi nói nốt cái vụ
Vũ kiểu cũng thế nhỉ nha À tôi cũng từng
làm tool để mà
đi tìm mấy bạn nữ kiểu để mái hẹn hò rồi
anh Bởi vì tôi từng thấy tin ơ đã cả cái
Facebook dep tinh nó rất là điểm nên tội
phải làm tôn riêng để mà để mà lấy lấy
ra những cái bạn phù hợp với mình đó là
theo kiểu là
ví dụ là thế nào là một bạn nữ phù hợp
với mình là bạn ấy phải thích những cái
mình thích đúng thì thì một là mấy ông
Tìm mấy bạn ấy ngoài đời nhưng K tìm bạn
ấy ngoài đời nó sẽ bị cái kiểu đã
cho tiếp cận bạn ấy ngoài đời mấy ông đã
lại rồi Chưa kể bạn đấy mà có người yêu
rồi thì còn kiểu khó xử hơn hay ra cách
để mà biết thì được công nên tìm hiểu
qua trên Facebook kiểu lướt qua Facebook
mới biết qua bạn ấy có miui không hả em
bạn đấy hay chia sẻ hay đang cái gì
chẳng hạn cũng hiểu rõ ná mà nó ngoạn
tiếp tiếp cận qua đấy thôi thở dễ dàng
hơn nên thành ra là
tôi tôi tiếp cận nhiều hình thức đấy đó
chị sẽ
đi tìm các bạn nữ tự nhiên là ở cùng
thành phố đúng không ạ ngồi Tìm tất cả
những bạn nữ ở cùng thành phố Hà Nội
chẳng ạ
em à Có phải bạn không khai độ tuổi thì
càng tốt và bạn thì không lọc chế độ độc
thân Như bạn kia nói nữa không đúng mà
Chỉ có nhiều bạn thì cứ để chế độ
quá tự nhiên có bạn để qua phụ có bạn
thì đợi chị hẹn hò với bạn nữ khác như
bạn gì gì đó nên là không không chơi
theo kiểu lập chế độ và lấy được nhưng
mấy ông hiểu ý tôi mà không ạ nghĩa lọc
lọc dần dùng tool để lọc chứ không phải
dùng chạy bằng cơm cái sau đó thì lấy là
cả những bạn cùng nhóm mình thích hay là
thích những cái fanpage mình thích chẳng
hạn đấy
ông này nói chung là làm nhiều cách đấy
rồi Tôi lấy ra tận Khôi đấy thôi Ngồi
Cắm máy chạy thay vì đào Bitcoin tôi
ngồi đào gái kiểu thế nào bạn gái rồi
hết tế bào da thật 80 hơn 80 nghìn bạn
gái nữ ở Hà Nội hồi đấy chưa biết bạn ấy
độc thân hay không nhưng mà nói chung ở
ra lần gần đấy rồi tôi
tôi có video
Ý tôi nói là tôi không cho mày không có
xem video này nhưng mà thôi Lỡ rồi gỡ
nói anh thế rồi không cho nữa chứ
Ừ nếu không sẽ hiểu được tôi làm sao tôi
ngồi à duyệt mấy bạn đấy như thế nào
[âm nhạc]
tôi tắt cái tiếng gọi tiếng to thế
em ở chỗ là hội này ra bạn gái kèm theo
tất cả ảnh của bạn đây tôi tôi sẽ ngồi
duyệt Thụ công sẽ bạn đấy phù hợp với
không
cẩn xóa duyệt hoặc ấn
thêm bạn Tại sao lại có cái vụ duyệt mà
không thấy bạn luôn bởi vì à tôi hồi đấy
nó tô còn làm vụ này cho gà mấy ông bạn
nữa tôi kiểu muốn chia sẻ cho mấy ông
bạn đấy
Ừ thế thì tôi sẽ hiển thị toàn bộ ảnh
của bạn đấy xem qua xem qua có hợp hay
không Tuy nhiên cái này Thực ra là tôi
chỉ cần đổi giới tính nam nữ hàng Nam mà
cả bao nhiêu Tôi có thể chia sẻ được cho
cạn mấy bạn nữ dùng luôn
Ừ đúng Hòa thận chế đổi Hà Nội thấy cái
gì đó thì sẽ tỉnh khác luôn Không ạ
tinder là chỉ dành cho mình cái người
nào đó mừng kiểu
anh có nhiều bạn độc thân ở đây có có
dùng tin đâu nữa không ạ xong rồi chia
sẻ những cái thông tin trên đấy có thể
nó không hoàn toàn là minh bạch bằng cái
nick Facebook của các bạn
em nghe cái này tôi nghĩa là nó nếu mà
đương nhiên là bây giờ thì Facebook nó
giới hạn để lấy mấy thông tin này các
ngữ hơn rồi cái việc là tôi không dùng
nó nữa kết hợp thế hết thì ra tôi từng
dùng nó để mà gặp đúng mà bạn Sau đó thì
tôi gặp bạn đấy Sao tôi không đúng là
không dùng cái này nữa thật nhưng mà ở
đấy mấy ông ấy biết được là khi mà Làm
lập trình kết hợp với cái mục đích của
mình nó thấy như thế nào Nói chung là nó
không hẳn thứ gì đó hay ho rồi khoe công
khai như này có thể khoe bạn mấy ông bạn
ạ Ông thì có biết thằng nó ngầu Thôi về
công thay gửi cái gì mấy hôm sau với bạn
nữ tẩy chay cái kênh này của tôi mất đi
Ừ nếu bạn nữ đừng có trách tôi nhé
à à
à À đúng rồi
có vài bạn chưa được biết thì sau cái
buổi hôm nay buổi cuối rồi ông ạ thì từ
tuần sau là mình sẽ chuyển sang học 3
buổi 1 tuần về quét hoàn toàn chứ không
còn học Will có từ từ nữa nhưng mà trong
lớp học web đấy thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn
về việc kết nối giữa
ngôn ngữ lập trình kết hợp về axwell thì
để giải quyết bài toán vấn đề nó như thế
nào ạ Ừ đấy thì cái data dữ liệu của tôi
vừa rồi năm mươi mấy nghìn bạn kia thì
cũng lưu lại trong axwell đấy đúng ạ Như
lại để mà lọc dần ạ
chỉ có mình vẫn sẽ livestream trên này
có thử vẫn như bình thường nhé của buổi
hôm nay cũng lâu phết 1 tiếng rưỡi rồi
mấy ông chả còn muốn chia sẻ gì nữa
Em hãy xem
em vẫn chưa mào đăng ký thêm hỏi flash
gì cả buồn nữa em có hỏi hôm nay nhiều
phết Hay là do các bạn thấy câu hỏi chán
nữa là không muốn hỏi nữa
hơi tiếc có phải câu ở trong này có vài
câu hay phết
anh ạ
chỉ có mình sẽ dạy về cả có một quan hệ
thực thể có từ thử nữa cho các bạn Nói
chung là từ đầu đến cuối để làm ra là
một cái sản phẩm mình mình sẽ dạy các
bạn từ đầu đến cuối như thế
à à
khi cài xtrend là cái đấy rõ lắm chắc là
mình sẽ
mình bạn thân mình cũng chưa biết hết
rồi nó các bạn chắc là chịu khó cha Thôi
expressway về em ạ
em trả lời 2 lần có ích hay điểm không
thấy ông ông kia vẫn hàm vụ trả lời thế
mà tôi đã điểm số như mì nói được ra các
bạn vui nhưng mà có điểm k hiện có sẽ
sẵn rồi nhưng mà
cả các bạn ạ Mình mình thấy các bạn nên
vui và nên khoe với mình nhất là khi các
bạn làm xong 10 sản phẩm gì đó các bạn
hãy liên Thế là các bạn khoe với mình
cái sản phẩm đấy Mình sẽ thấy tự hào Khi
mà có sinh viên kiểu như thế làm được
làm tốt hơn cả mình mình cần tự hào hơn
đúng không ạ nhà anh chơi hết các bạn cư
học sau đó là mũi gì đó mình thấy rất
nhiều bạn chưa sẻ trên cái
cái kênh Tech cái bồ của mình anh phá
kiểu tâm huyết của một bài tập của mình
mình nghĩa các bạn làm không thể đối phó
gì cả Bởi vì nó khác trên trường học
theo cỡ là đây là tự nguyện nên các bạn
làm không hay đối phó thì bạn làm hết
sức có tâm mình tin là các bạn tốn nhiều
thời gian hơn nửa tiếng hay thận chế một
tiếng để làm mấy cái bài tập đấy
anh ạ
từ lúc đi thực tập mình từng có nói qua
rồi đó hồi đấy mình được cả phụ cấp rất
là
anh ơi ít hội đầu hồi làm parttime thiểu
500 sau đó lên vì sao làm nên fulltime
về được một triệu trong đó tiền ăn tiền
ăn trưa vì mình vẫn qua lại ăn chưa đấy
thì ạ
mất 600 rồi thành ra là kiểu ở một tháng
chứ Còn bốn trăm tiền xăng xe nữa Thế
nên là mình bảo đi thực tập từ ngày này
nó Cậu bị bóc lột một phần là do cái
công ty đấy sát nên mình cũng không còn
rơi ra được chính nhân Nếu mà đi được
tập của ngành này là các bạn cần học hỏi
chưa có bạn tạm bỏ qua việc tiền hay
bằng cấp hai dì Vân Vân
bởi vì về các bạn thì nó giống như kiểu
các bạn được tiền để đi học đấy Kiểu cái
thế
cho đi học trường tiền trên trường mấy
ông có tiền còn đi hỏng kia thì miếu
không mất tiền mà được tiền nhé Thế vẫn
là tốt mà nó không ạ
Ừ mình thì không chưa đủ Mình chưa đủ
kinh nghiệm 2 á kiến thức để mà làm cái
cái liên quan đến các ngôn ngữ khác đâu
thế nên là chắc à Cái vụ này thì các bạn
tham khảo ở mấy người nước ngoài thì
chuẩn hơn có rất nhiều kênh nhớ ngoài
mình thể lập trình viên có những thứ
nhân và đôi nha các bạn phải biết thêm
tiếng Anh để mày nghe đúng không ạ nhưng
mà xứng đáng hơn phù hợp kiến thức các
họ cũng rộng hơn mình
à mình Mình thì đang hướng đến mình
không hẳn hưởng hướng đến đối tượng kiểu
lòng mấy cái bạn mới học thôi Còn những
bạn À biết rồi thì thì mình mình hướng
đến là từ đầu đến cuối cho
a cho một bạn chưa biết gì cho đến bạn
đến đủ trình độ ngang bằng mình đã theo
Thế mẹ hướng đến như thế cho những trình
độ mà vượt xa hơn xa hơn được cậu ấy rất
chuyên sâu quá thì chắc mình không đáp
ứng được
an ninh vật nát mình có ghim ở kia kìa
a pair of paper tape hết cái thứ hoa
à mình mình thấy những cái câu hỏi kia
chắc là để buổi sau quét trả lời sau nhé
các bạn có muốn chia sẻ để nữa ông ạ
những bạn đã ngon đấy
anh mất tích rồi à
à à
tôi hỏi chả bội hôm nay tạm kết thúc đấy
nhá bữa hôm nay cũng rất là dài rồi Mình
cảm thấy rất hạnh phúc khi mà đã có
nhiều người xem như thế này
Ừ anh thấy hết cho tai nạn nhiên buổi
cuối có khác đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ Chúc các bạn buổi tối tốt lành Chào
bạn nhé ạ
Em chúc thầy ngày nhà giáo 20